you guys may remember this barack obama
guy does he ring a bell does that name
sound like something
in 2008 he said that gas tax holidays
were complete nonsense i know that we're
having a debate right now about the gas
tax holiday
[Applause]
i know how brutal
this is on folks right now
and i know they need relief which is why
i've offered a middle-class tax cut for
every american a thousand dollars for
working families so that they can deal
not only with
rising gas prices but rising health care
costs and rising grocery costs
but for us to suggest that
30 cents a day
for three months
is real relief
that that's a real energy policy
means that we are not tackling the
problem that has to be tackled
man if joe biden had any clue what was
going on he would not be happy hearing
that from barack obama who he ended up
being vp for
uh libby i mean obama 2008 making a lot
of sense that's when it was going to
save you 30 cents a gallon now we're
only at 18 cents a gallon
yeah but what we see with this
administration consistently uh with
regard to energy and resources as well
as all of the other things
from you know abortion and trans rights
and whatever else we see a desire on
their part to remake american society
and remake the american economy to fit
their utopian ideal of what they think
we should be doing they don't care about
average american people they don't care
about how we're going to feed our
families they don't care about how we're
going to fill our tanks or drive around
or lead our lives in the independent and
individualistic ways that we would
prefer to no instead they want us to
rely on their own
ideas of um what they believe is
appropriate whether it's the sun and the
and the wind
or whatever else the electric vehicles
that actually run on coal power and they
refuse to actually admit that that's
what's going on our grid can't handle
this stuff and they've also been waging
a war against nuclear energy which is
profoundly stupid since nuclear energy
is clean uh efficient and effective and
could do an awful lot in order to power
and shape our economy um but no they
they have this absurd moral view and
they just want us to do what they say
and i'm so sick of it i hate it so much
libby you're giving me answers to a
problem but you're forgetting about some
other guy across the world who we have
to blame for all of our problems we even
have video of somebody blaming that guy
video
and let's remember how we got here
putin invaded ukraine
putin invaded ukraine with a hundred
thousand forces
so for all those republicans in congress
criticizing me today for high gas prices
in america
are you now saying we were wrong to
support ukraine
are you saying we were wrong to stand up
to putin
are you saying that we would rather have
lower gas prices in america and putin's
iron fist in europe
all right first off yes i think a lot of
people are saying that uh number two gas
as we've covered here many times was up
already a dollar over a dollar a gallon
before putin went into ukraine et cetera
et cetera dave it's pretty good to have
somebody you can blame for all of your
problems i mean i thought the job of a
president was that you know other guys
do bad stuff and you're supposed to
respond in kind not just blame them for
all of your problems
yeah i mean it's ridiculous we see that
it's ridiculous but um
it's a continuation of
what seemed to work out pretty well for
the democrats for the last five six
years which is just
putin is the boogeyman
and if you know if you were
if you were a democrat strategist
one of the smart things to do would be
to pin
negative
news and all your bad things on the guy
that you just spent five years uh uh
affirmating against
um and blaming for everything from the
2016 election to
you know to everything just put
everything else in that in that bucket
and it seems to me like the democrat
electorate
um has has thus far
accepted it
um you know i i don't think i i think
that
that crowd of people as we've seen from
the uh from the uh the approval
polling for joe biden i think that that
number is is is dropping like a stone
but still this is this is kind of what
they've got to do in order to
get the attention and the motivation of
their most hardcore supporters